thank thank you very much probably
listening to the very end of the last
talk i'm one of those people who is
pursuing a particular technology and so
everything i say probably has a little
bit of a bias on the other hand i think
it's very hard to predict the future and
so I think we need multiple options to
move forward and I'll try something here
which is a little bit outside of the
normal box of how to think about things
so i would like to argue that it is
actually possible to get co2 back out of
the air at a price you can afford and if
that's true it opens all sorts of
interesting options you can you can make
fuels out of it or you could bury it
depending on what you want to do with it
so let me just sort of as a matter of
disclosure say we start I started to
think about this in 1999 in 2003 in the
winter of 2003-2004 while he broker
introduced me to Gary como who used to
own land sand and Gary got very
interested in climate change issues and
he got interested enough that he put
money up to form a small private company
with which I have been involved since so
I have an interest in this which goes
past the academic side but I would argue
i'm interested in it because i started
it and so I leave it to you to decide to
which extent i'm worrying about the
academic issues and to what extent i'm
worrying about more commercial issues
but i do think it is one of those
fundamental things which can change how
you think about the problem so without
arguing to begin with can we do it let's
assume we could do it and why would it
be interesting and I would argue the
biggest first step it gives you it
separates the sources of co2 from the
sinks of co2 because the air is a
conveyor which can transport the co2
over large distances without really a
big side effect you could imagine having
a car driving in Los Angeles and it
emits co2 into the atmosphere and that
co2 will mix in very well and in a
matter of weeks it sort of has circled
the globe
in a matter of months it has spread out
into him in a hemisphere in two years it
has spread out between the two
hemispheres and since we are not worried
about the change in a matter of months
or weeks in the co2 in the world we
could literally pick up that co2 in the
Australian desert and dispose of it
right there so you you are not tight to
your source anymore you suddenly have
the ability to make things happen far
apart the other thing you could start
thinking about it is the emissions could
also be emissions from the past so you
can start reducing the co2 content of
the atmosphere again if you really can
do that but of course this makes no
sense until you stabilize co2 before
that you are just another sequestration
option option another capture option
ultimately I think what makes it really
interesting is the idea that it allows
for closed fuel cycles where you have
co2 the ash coming from the air you take
it with new energy and convert it back
into a fuel and then of course from a
practical point of view in the short
term there are commercial applications
for co2 which allows us to sort of have
a bootstrap from where we are to way we
would like to be but the underlying
problem of course is the problem of co2
in the atmosphere and this graph is only
to highlight some of the issues with
that and the point I want to make is
this graph here which is labeled
continued exponential growth is simply
saying we keep doing more or less what
we were doing the last 100 200 years and
this would go off the chart before the
century is out the point I really want
to stress is even in 2010 we had figured
out how to stop the growth in emissions
and hold emissions constant we would
follow this curve so if you take the
European view that point 8 50 points per
million is sort of the limit you should
get to in my view it really doesn't
matter that much anymore whether you
help things constant or whether you kept
exponentially growing you just delay the
time you breach that boundary a little
later in other words in many ways the
problem is like a stock problem rather
than a flow problem roughly speaking
half of the co2 we put out and you see
you see this
behavior which comes from the fact that
some of the co2 ends up in the ocean
this is a simple impulse response model
which which allowed for doing this but
would you really see that over hundreds
of years roughly half of the co2 be put
out actually stays in the atmosphere and
then it's simple arithmetic 1 Giga tonic
carbon is worth half a ppm if I say half
of it gets away I need for gigatonnes of
carbon to add 1 ppm to the atmosphere we
are currently putting out eight giga
tons a year and so you can now figure
out how much time do we have before we
hit the 450 mark and we can quibble on
the ten percent realm that I got they
factor for right or and that also
depends on whether you are fast or slow
because there are some time constants
absorbing some of the co2 but my point
is we really have to come down to
drastic reductions and is not good
enough to just go after the power plants
because the power plants are only a
third of the total roughly so you have
to go after the distributed sources as
well so to give you a feeling if 450 ppm
is the number you deal with you can then
say well there's a 60 ppm left we have
reached the 390 recently so we are we
are 60 ppm away times four is 240
gigatonnes of carbon divide that by the
average population in the next 50 years
of 8 billion people and you have 30
tonnes per person so your personal
allowance is a track like this this is
about 30 tons of gasoline and so think
of having that parked in front of your
housing every time you go somewhere
every time you fly somewhere a little of
it is taken out in the scale at which
things go in the u.s. that tanker truck
is empty for the average person in
roughly five six years so so that sets
the scale of how tough it is to actually
hold the 450 mark this is for nachos
your life this is for the life of your
children in children's children because
this is a stock problem so I basically
said you have a total budget of roughly
30 tons per person left
and I took a slightly higher yeah and
and that's the this could take
infinitely that you could do this
infinitely long but if you truly you
have a few hundred years if you if you
make the time constants much longer than
that you see other processes picking up
the seal trip I used eight yeah I used
eight billion people to get 30 so I
allowed for that roughly but but we can
quibble with its 40 tons or 25 tons but
the point is the budget is surprisingly
small and it it there's nothing new in
this number but people don't tell it to
you this way and if it's told to you
this way and I'm in an airport and I see
all that that that jet fuel being put
into my airplane I start feeling guilty
so if you it is quite possible and some
people will tell you that the 450 ppm
mark is clearly too high I see no
practical way to actually stop at 450 we
probably will overshoot that but we may
have to come down even lower than that
and some people have suggested 350 and I
would argue without having a captcha is
one of your tools you really can't even
do that so it seems to me we have to
think about whether this is possible and
just as an end of the introduction let
me point out the problem is not self
limiting there is enough fossil carbon
in the ground that we probably could
have 5000 gigatonnes of carbon so we
could have we could go to 2,000 ppm if
you chose to do so it's not that we are
limited coal resources are estimated
somewhere between 3000 and 5000 gigatons
these are not proven reserves there's a
difference there and people argue about
what precisely are the proven reserves
and I think part of it is what precisely
do you mean by proven reserves in and so
it's what you could do at current price
but assume there is no more oil and
there is no more call but they are still
4,000 gigatonnes I call in Alaska we do
figure out how to spread that over the
rest of the world but right now nobody
in his right
would counted in the reserves right so
what's growing very rapidly particularly
in the US and but also in China is shale
gas so so we really are at a point where
you might actually even see gas to
liquid substituting for coal I would
actually argue a price well above 100
dollars a barrel is not economically
sustainable because if people were sure
that you couldn't come down from that
anymore I think alternatives like gas to
liquid or coal to liquid would actually
enter we know it can be done more
cheaply than that and in a way all those
resources are fungible making all those
fuels on the other hand and so I would
conclude that without carbon capture and
storage fossil fuels have to be phased
out and is a coral area would say liquid
fuels in the transportation sector also
would have to be phased out and their
capture cannot happen on board an
airplane cannot carry home to see or to
it makes even if you could figure out
how to capture it and because it can't
handle the weight because it's three
times the weight of the fuel and your
card you would have some six big
cylinders of co2 in the back of your
trunk by the time you get back to a
filling station to refill the car I
don't think it's practical to even
consider the option to do this on board
so as I probably have said here in a
talk before I really see only three big
options which are big enough to give 10
billion people energy at the scale we in
the developed countries take for granted
so you need to think in tens of terra
watts and I think the three options
which are big enough solar energy
nuclear energy and fossil energy for
maybe a hundred or two hundred years if
you fix the carbon capture and storage
problem and so I think it's very
important to really seriously start
thinking about how to get all three to
the scale you need and if you get rid of
the fossil fuels then the other two have
to figure out in some way or another how
to deal with the transportation sector
and in my view the best option there is
to provide liquid fuels so when I would
argue air capture has a role in all of
these case
because if the answer is fossil fuels
then carbon capture and storage is
needed and I would argue see co2 capture
from the air is capture of last resort
if you have something which is cheaper
than that they're all means go ahead but
cars and airplanes and then are
unavoidably going into the air and I
would argue their fugitive emissions if
you are talking about a power plant
roughly ten percent of that will escape
and it's getting economically expensive
to get it there if geoengineering is the
answer and I don't talk about that here
then you can think of the reduction of
atmospheric co2 and stabilizing it at
the desired level as a geoengineering
option and again I think you would need
the capture of co2 just to keep it cold
and leprosy or to pile up under it
doesn't make sense in my view it's a
little bit like saying we solve the
garbage problem by putting houses on
stilts and we raise them every year a
little because that's what you would
have to do because they co2 levels would
keep going up and up and up and I think
if you have non-fossil infrastructures
you need energy storage and you need
transportation fuels and again your
capture would allow you to do that
because it would bring you in the carbon
atoms you would want to close that loop
so and I would make a pitch for liquid
fuels on boards of vehicles rather than
rather than electricity in form of
batteries and the simple argument I'll
put forward there's lithium-ion battery
give it's a high-performance end is
roughly half a mega Joule per kilogram
this tank gasoline is roughly 50 mega
joules a kilogram there's a good two
orders of magnitude difference between
the two and so not even knowing anything
about it if you have battery cars
working well and I came along and say we
place that battery with a fuel cell you
suddenly would have you are your 200
mile range changed into a 10,000 mile
range and so you could fill up your car
one sippy every year so clearly people
would like that transition there is some
intrinsic advantage to those liquids and
I think it's worth trying to fight for
them and see where
you can have so having told you why I'm
interested now let me give you a brief
summary yia think it's possible and be
how we go about it to make it possible
so the first observation I started with
was nearly coincidental because in some
entirely different context i started
wives myself how much co2 is actually in
a cubic meter of air which has roughly
40 moles of air and one part in 2,500
400 ppm would give you roughly point one
point six percent of a mole of co2 in
that cubic meter of air and if you now
say I need an energy equivalent because
I want to think in energy terms as well
if I combust gasoline and make that much
co2 how much he do I actually release
and it's a simple arithmetic it's ten
thousand joules what struck me is that
we built windmills and the windmills go
after the kinetic energy of that same
cubic meter of air and it's a simple
calculation em over 2v squared is the
kinetic energy and if I go into a place
where you would put a vent mail at about
6 meters a second you can calculate a
move MV squared over 2 to be 20 joules
so what what struck me that day is there
was a factor of five hundred in favor of
the co2 concentration in the air over
the kinetic energy and so I left I left
this where they feel like this is worth
looking at a little harder because if
there if there is so much more co2 than
kinetic energy in the air yet we think
we can build windmills one should
investigate this a little more closely
and so basically if you build some co2
scrubber that is a sort of an artist
concept how it might look the thing the
thing which is interesting is its orders
of magnitude smaller for the same carbon
reduction then event melt so after
looking at some costs I said well if I'm
really dumb about it it is right when I
started I'm going to say this has a
capital cost and it has a certain per
square meter of rondalee area that let's
say has the same let me calculate the
price of a ton of co2 if the price of
electricity is five cents a kilowatt
hour
and I need one more assumption is that
the collection efficiencies of those two
are maybe the same 30-some percent or
whatever you pick and if you make that
assumption you find that the price of
five cents per kilowatt-hour is
equivalent to fifty cents per ton of co2
so I said I could be orders of magnitude
off with this calculation and maybe it's
ten times more expensive but what it
suggests is that contracting the air
passively just to extract the co2 is not
where your cost is likely to be and we
actually found that out in the future as
we now going back from 1999 when I
started to think about it you today if
you actually add up all the cost of the
material we have to hold in the wind
it's not that high it may not be fifty
cents but it's not much more than five
dollars a ton right and I think we can
actually drive it even below that if we
keep working on it my point is the
contacting is not the issue but on the
other hand once you have contacted the
the air and the co2 had to be absorbed
because I cannot afford compressing
there I cannot for a Ford heating the
air I cannot afford cooling the air so
all I really can do is have assortment
in there which which binds the co2 and
now my job is to get it back off
whatever bounded because i can't imagine
that i can get some stuff I can throw
away with a co2 because it would usually
be too expensive so I need to have a
regenerable sore butt and now I look
just like a power plant flue gas
scrubber except I need a stronger sore
right and so I can take their costs as a
lower limit of what I could possibly do
I now have absorb the co2 on some
material X could be calcium hydroxide it
quickly sodium hydroxide I'll show you
something better in a second but
whatever it is I now have to rip the CEO
to back off and repeat this and this
challenge just like the job they have
and so the question is is our job much
much harder than there's always a
comparable and I would argue yes the
concentration is roughly 300 times lower
but that's not as bad as it sounds and
the reason I'm making that argument is
that if you calculate the Sorbonne
strength you need to absorb down to
particular level I started 400 parts per
million in the atmosphere so I have a
very tiny amount and I'm not after
creating co2 free air so I'm perfectly
happy to stop at three hundred or 200
ppm and say that's the end of the line
because i don't i won't see or two I
don't want co2 free air whereas the
power plant has to take kneeling all of
it out and so therefore they have to
come down to one percent or Oh point one
percent so the factory is not 300
anymore but it's around 30 and then
thermodynamics is with you in that these
Orban strength only scales
logarithmically in that in that number
right and so as a result for every
factor 2 i'm less concentrated i need an
extra epsilon in energy and it turns out
here i plot the actual curves and I
cheat a little by pointing out that the
power plant has to be a little harder
they probably are 350 Kelvin I may be at
300 Kelvin I may even be a little lower
but taking those two numbers you see
this is the range for the power plant
this is ninety-nine percent captured as
it's ten percent captured and this is
where air capture would be in this Orban
strengths so my point is I'm not
particularly much stronger I'm a little
stronger but not particularly much
stronger so be and as an aside people
say well he did the thermodynamics wrong
and therefore don't trust his answer so
I actually sat down and worked it out
carefully and the answer is the free
energy of mixing is not that simple RT
log P it's theirs RT times this whole
long thing so I worked it out and I said
well if i just take an epsilon out of
the air and i just take the tiniest
little bit and I take that limit of this
complicated formula I go through this
and I get my RT log P so so much my
point is the people who said he's wrong
actually calculated a number which is
slightly lower than mine so if I just
take the free energy of mixing I could
be out here and take nearly all of it
out and I would sit on that black line
whereas I would have said I need a
sorbent which can do that and that's an
irreversible process
these all burnt it has has to be
stronger than and got you all the way
from here down to there right and so for
most co2 molecules coming in it was too
strong so I needed a little more energy
and by the way as I go to zero it would
go to infinity so we are roughly eight
percent more than the fancy formula
would suggest but that's because we
assume we do it in a single torben and
and so we then find out that we have a
certain efficiency we can get to so but
the conclusion i have from that is that
the dominant costs are likely to be
quite similar right and in the end the
proof is in the pudding i would argue i
can't i can't go much more but back at
the envelope statements as saying that I
see it is reasonable that the final cost
of collecting co2 from the air will be
higher than scrubbing a flue gas stack
but it will not be orders of magnitude
higher I need a solvent which is twenty
thirty percent maybe one and a half
times as strong and so the energy I need
to close the loop is a little higher
than theirs if we are in the perfect
limit so if they are you they can get
down to thirty dollars right now and
some people say well we could do it at
fifteen dollars a ton well we have to
see where they end up and if they get
gradually perfect we would be maybe one
and a half times their costs so so I
would argue we can get quite cheap as
well and that's sort of what drove us to
make it happen but then of course what
becomes very clear is your sorban choice
is central now if you have a good
solvent you can make this work so we
looked at all sorts of things and we
started like everybody else you can take
sodium hydroxide and sure enough it
works it works very well on the capture
side it's very cheap on the capture side
but now the co2 is really bound then you
can't get it off easily and so we
finally ended up with a with a resin
material and anionic exchange resin
which is a polystyrene and it has very
interesting features it's quite cheap
it's made by the truckload quite
literally you can buy it from Chinese
vendors right now a two dollar fifty a
kilogram and it loads up
in it when it's dry it absorbs and when
it's wet it gives it back so here's your
polystyrene with a quaternary ammonium
attached and that acts like the sodium
in a sodium hydroxide solution so now
the negative ion when I buy this stuff
is a chloride I washed it out and made
it a hydroxide not surprisingly it will
pick up a co2 and turn into a carbonate
what surprise does it picked up a second
co2 and it turned into a bicarbonate and
in moving from carbonate to buy
carbonate a sheet of this material and
let me see here here you see that we
actually had it in sheet form a sheet of
this material is it still as fast as a
one molar sodium hydroxide solution
covering a similar sheet so so the
upshot is the kinetics is as good as
sodium hydroxide but I'm moving from
carbonate to buy company that alone got
as excited because the the energetics of
swinging between carbonate and
bicarbonate is much more favorable than
the energetics of swinging between
hydroxide and carbonate but then we
found out that if the dry raisin will do
that the wet resin actually falls back
to the carbonate and that we call the
moisture swing and we got really excited
about this so here you see some of this
material in various forms and so the
sheets absorb co2 from here they absorb
down to balogh partial pressures with
the empty you can easily go to one or
two ppm in the air air loading can reach
bicarbonate and the equilibrium is water
sensitive so we had experiment setup
like a bell like that where we did it
inside then we replaced it with a small
loop where we go around and so you see
here data where the red line is the co2
content in the gas phase so if it goes
up the recent releases if it goes down
the resin absorbs and the blue line is
the moisture in this Soviet ways you're
changing the moisture level in the gas
and so you see whenever we make it right
it absorbs co2 whenever we make it wet
it gives it back and so we can swing it
back and forth as many times as we like
here's an isotherm so this
the loading of the resin as functional
partial pressure when the air has when
the air has about a dew point around
freezing so this is desert air in Tucson
Arizona as a matter of fact where we
doing things and so you see this nice
curve as it loads loads up and notice at
22 400 ppm it's essentially fully loaded
here is the same curve at slightly
different temperatures when the material
is wet and notice the change is
essentially in the scale these are
kilopascals or percenter co2 whereas the
previous scale with PPM's so basically
the scale shifted by roughly affect 100
to 200 and stretched out simply by
making things but now what we believe
happens is that in the wet ski system we
see the same carbonate skate chemistry
as you see in aqueous sodium carbonate
solutions and bicarbonate solutions
whereas when it's dry the individual
ions will hang on to a hydroxide and
converted to a bicarbonate but the
neighbor doesn't know about it it's too
far away and so the bike carbonates are
there all along all the way until it's
full you also see that the maximum
loading falls up if I make the air too
moist so it won't work very well in the
tropics it works very well in a desert
but we believe we can change the race
for the engineers in the room we
actually change the thermodynamic
argument once more a little because what
we have is dry air coming in and then
later liquid water and what comes out is
co2 enriched air and moist air so we pay
a part of the energy bill by the simple
fact that there is free energy available
if water evaporates so in a funny way
half of the energy penalty to get from
co2 in the air to have liquid co2 is
paid by evaporating what right and so we
cannot stop using water because if we
did we have no energy source but if I
put this water here on the cupboard
which it probably shouldn't do but in a
couple of hours they would have gone
away because there's free energy to bh
have spontaneously it will move out so
if you look at the steps we have dry
resin absorb co2 from the air
that lowers its free energy then the
reason is weighted which really
shouldn't do anything maybe it if
anything the water ranges itself to
lower the free energy even more and then
we make it releases spontaneously see
you at 0 so clearly this is a gainer up
here downhill and then the last step
which you have to account for as well
and I think that's why people were
concerned about thermodynamics the last
step is the resin price and that happens
spontaneously in the air in the wind so
so we don't add that work as work so we
work a little bit like an air
conditioning system in a desert climate
which makes things cool by evaporating
water we have the water release the co2
again and then in the end for the cycle
to close the water actually has to
evaporate and so we roughly consume
cubic meter 10 kilograms of water per
kilogram of co2 but if I translate this
into a into a cost its tiny even if i
had to desalinate the water by the way i
could afford that and i can i can think
of it as a source of free energy which
costs me roughly half a cent a kilowatt
hour so from that point of view using
water i think is completely justified in
this case so basically we have these
things in the air we put them in a box
and make it wet now we have two options
either we evacuate the box before we
make it wet then we get five percent of
an atmosphere of pressure inside which
is co2 in some water vapor or we put it
back into the air then we have five
percent co2 in the gas stream and at
this point we didn't pay much energy at
all except for the water and now you
could go with a conventional process and
close the loop all the way to the top I
think it's smarter well we can debate
that but i believe it's smarter to
actually evacuate the alternative is to
capture it a second time and the
question may be what kind of energy you
have if you have electricity then it's
nice to run compressors and pumps which
you have to do if you have a vacuum
based system if you run a second sorban
you may use heat to close the loop so
here's sort of a small picture of
something which could do it we assume we
have one meter as
and going through our uptake rates
around 25 micro moles per square meter
per second and so our release rates so
we need we have a specific surface area
this is older we are better now of 24
square meters per kilogram this is not
the tiny nooks and crannies in there but
it's the layers of the material itself
and so we fill the filter volume with
about ten percent of the stuff and the
upshot is if you wanted a ton a day you
would look at a system which is about as
big as a container it would sit on top
and you could move the whole thing
around inside your container we have
then worked out what that might cost and
the point I stress is people always tell
you well it's the cost goes linearly in
the concentration we would argue we are
in a regime where it still goes linearly
with a log of the concentration or the
dilution factor right and I think that's
an important argument and people give
you a counter we said well you know if
you look at OSU mine then indeed it goes
the cost of the metal is is linearly the
dilution factor and this is known as
Sherwood's law and you see this
beautiful plot here but notice it's log
log and I want to point out how much
lower bromine from seawater is and it's
not it's because it's not a rock if you
calculate where the slope comes from for
all the mining it turns out there is a
similar slope for for pharmaceuticals
which I think has similar arguments
attached but if you calculate it for
mining what you get is that the price of
a metal is roughly ten dollars per ton
of ore and if you ask what did you just
pay for you paid for great for digging
up the rock for crushing the rock for
grinding the rock and do the first
extraction anything beyond that is in
the noise compared to those first terms
so in that case is clearly the linear
term which dominates because the big
cost is the mining and dealing getting
rid of the 10x whereas in our case where
we are passing air through a system
that's not where the cost is the cost is
still in the second step which here
tends to be invisible so I think this
argument is simply not right so we did
first cost estimates I
could spend an hour on this here and I
don't want to do that unless you're
really interested but basically we found
the materials cost in our devices is low
the manufacturer costs the first time
around is very high and we figured that
one time a day unit the first time is
two hundred thousand dollars right the
operating costs the inputs of a low the
maintenance is high because if you had
time today and you have 30 minutes over
person there you just spent thirty
dollars a ton of three or two right and
so we figured the operating cost is
about one hundred twenty dollars a ton
on the first try and we end up with a
total cost some of you two hundred and
two hundred fifty dollars by Tennessee
or two that has built in a return on the
investment I would like to stress this
is a first-of-a-kind so if I came to you
today and then you know you need to
build a car in a machine shop you also
would have a two-hundred-thousand-dollar
item on your hands and as a matter of
fact if you build a car other spare
parts it costs more than that because
because spare parts are priced much
higher than the car itself so I do
believe that there is an enormous amount
we're learning can drive costs down and
factors 54 so I actually not that
horrible but i do want to translate
these costs and i do want to point out
that a hundred dollars per ton of co2
will translate into 22 cents per liter
of gasoline or if you are in this
country eighty-five cents per gallon if
you get it down to thirty dollars this
is seventy cents per liter of gasoline
or twenty-five cents a gallon the other
number i want to point out that gasoline
a liter of gasoline has roughly 10
kilowatt hours of chemical energy in it
because i'm going to use that number in
a minute so this sums up where I see why
I see this as interesting because even
at a hundred dollars a ton it starts
getting interesting I think at thirty
dollars a ton this would be cheaper than
any carbon tax I could imagine because
you end up you end up actually doing
have half your cake and eat at which
they say I'm not as concerned there was
an ApS study which that the costs are
going to be horrible and their their
particular process was estimated at six
hundred dollars a ton I have to say I
agree with it when I estimated the same
cause process I came up at a thousand
dollars a ton so within some small
factors we tend to agree but I i think
if you look at if you take that point of
view you couldn't build an electric car
because I calculated that the Tesla
avoids the China Sea or two if it really
avoids it doesn't emit it from the
tailpipe it may admit it at a power
plant but the cost of moving it there
cost you roughly six hundred dollars a
ton of co2 taking their costs for
batteries into account if you look at
fuel cells if you look at batteries if
you look at photovoltaics all of these
or went for that matter 30 years ago all
of these start out at prices which are
an order of magnitude higher then you in
the end meet and I think there is a
fundamental fallacy in calculate
estimating costs up front and I give you
the example of one of those little
cd-roms the first one I bought i spent
twenty dollars on right today they are
about ten cents per disc now my point is
in nineteen eighty if i asked you to
make a reasonable cost estimate you
couldn't have come up with a proper cost
estimate telling me ten cents a kilowatt
hour because if you had you would know
how to do it and and so there's a
paradox there right you can't you you
can't predict where prices will end up
and I think the honest answer is we will
not know but just because you are a
factor five too expensive at the start
doesn't mean you couldn't get there
that's that that that's my point and so
you have to be careful if you if you
just make an incremental change I think
it's fine to calculate the cost and say
I do i do not want to make that
incremental change if you start talking
about new approaches new technologies I
think you have to say are there some
physical laws which there you can't
possibly do it and if that's the answer
well then you should forget it but if
you just say manufacturing costs are
high you can't really make an argument
and I think the thermodynamics i can
calculate how much heat i would need to
make this happen on the order of 60
kilojoules per mole and i can ask how
much does it cost to provide that it's
cheap right if i ask how much does the
material cost
it's chi right I can't do it but with
low-cost right now to pull it all
together but that is precisely where
learning can make a difference so then
you can say well maybe it's it's
worthless because you couldn't possibly
get to scale so let's assume I stay with
the one-ton add a unit and I mass
manufacture them and I bring them out to
where you would want them give you an
example you may think of having a small
oil well which benefits from enhanced
oil recovery but it's too small to
justify a long pipeline so we could put
ten hundred thousand units in that place
in order to provide the co2 to run this
your but whichever we end up doing if
you had 10 million units out there in
the market I think you are starting to
be a real player you make a difference
and the argument is if you have 10
million units at one time a day give it
360 days in a year you have 3.6 gigatons
of co2 per year that's twelve percent of
the world's emission right now so at
that point you are player assume their
last ten years then you have to build 1
million per year in order to maintain
your stock and you should compare that
with building 70 million cars and light
trucks and again I would argue if they
are two hundred thousand dollars
building a machine shop there their cost
and complexity is not that much
different from what you would expect
from building a car or a small truck so
the order of magnitude you have
available in current production capacity
out there actually fire exceeds what you
would need then if you wanted a hundred
million units out there everything has
to be scaled up by a faculty 10 but you
could still do this and by the way you
know from this because they are billion
cars parked somewhere there's actually
room to put them and people have a
tendency to put them in a row and say oh
my god she can cross the United States
several times to collect enough co2 I
would like to point out because I did
the calculation if you take all the
windmills in the u.s. right now and put
them side by side they've across the
continent and Enza so seems to me if he
I capture is interesting and feasible
first place it could play a role is
creating a net carbon economy with
fossil fuels
so in such a world you would have to
dispose of the co2 and I don't want to
talk about how to do this here today but
you would also need it from the
concentrated sources and it would be
silly to laid it out and then run after
it again from the air but you have
roughly half of all emissions which come
from distributed sources and that would
be a niche for air capture in order to
make all of that work I think ultimately
you would need a rule which says for
every ton of carbon coming out of the
ground another ton has to be put away so
if i had to do cap-and-trade I would do
it directly at the well and say you dug
up carbon either as oil or as gas or as
coal you you are putting some you are
mobilizing so much carbon show me a
certificate of sequestration that you
put an equal amount back away now in the
short term you would have permits and
credits to balance the books because
overnight nobody can put that much
carbon away but you would have a promise
that this gradually goes away and so you
would be left with doing it this way and
of course air capture could play a role
in this market it's not the only one it
could be the utility which gives the
coal plant the coal mine the co2
sequestration certificates which come
from that coal directly but of course
they will fall ten percent short and I
think the long-term promise has to be
that it's a one to one right if that
were the case then you can think of as
air capture as being part of that mix as
one of the capture options and I think
it's the capture option of last resort
because it can deal with any co2 it
doesn't care where it came from and of
course lower capture options come first
right so if your power plant can do it
at half price by all means take the co2
at the power plant right but more
expensive options simply cannot compete
anymore so as a result air capture
becomes the marginal cost it will set
the marginal cost if it is playing at
all and it has advantages to write a
capture eliminates transport costs if
you are here in New York City no matter
how well you captured you see or two you
won't have much of a chance to get it
out of here
at least it at exorbitant prices so you
may in certain places prefer to admit it
because you can't afford the the
the transport it opens remote sites if
you think of mineral sequestration in
Oman you have enormous deposits of
serpentine there there is no practical
way to move them from there and it's not
practical to move co2 there except by
wind and then you have air capture and
you can deal with passed emissions so
you could actually say that government
agencies start buying tearing up
certificates of sequestration's in order
to get excess and then you could
actually come down that curve lastly I
think there's an ultimate application
for this and that's making synthetic
fuels and I believe that the two
complementary energy carriers in the
world electricity which is very
responsive to demand no emissions at the
point of consumption stationary
applications it's just ideal for but
it's very difficult to store right and
on the other side you have liquid fuels
they are very easily stored i think
that's their claim to fame you can have
a you can have a tank out in a harbor a
big big container container and the cost
of that / / kilowatt hour of stored
energy is is incredibly low so you can
actually have the gasoline in there for
a year or two and the extra cost of the
gasoline is actually quite small you can
store it for the transportation sector
but you could also store it for the
electricity sector and I would argue if
you have seasonal change seasonal
storage or or even weekly storage
batteries are way too expensive to make
this work and it has an extremely high
energy density but it does put out co2
at the point of use and what connects
the two carriers i think is electrolysis
and fuel synthesis so you have low
temperature you can make hydrogen from
water with solid oxide fuel cells at
high temperatures you can make CO and
hydrogen from co2 and water and then
once you have synthesis gas or co2 and
hydrogen for that matter you can have
hydrogen you can have methanol you can
have dimethyl ether and
if you have those or you start again
with synthesis gas you can make gasoline
and diesel excellen has a process to go
from DME to gasoline fischer-tropsch can
go from from co and hydrogen to gasoline
and diesel so there are ways of closing
that loop and the ingredients in a liter
of gasoline to just put this together
would be at fifty dollars a ton of co2
roughly ten cents of carbon a carbon
dioxide and at fifty percent efficiency
recalled in 10 kilowatt hours I give you
a minute ago you would need 20 kilowatt
hours of electricity to make a liter of
gasoline so if you are off peak that
could be as little as forty cents so so
my point is taking all of that together
I actually have the ingredients to think
about how to make this happen so in the
past people talk about the hydrogen
cycle and they sort of have this view
you have a power generator which
separates water into oxygen and hydrogen
the oxygen is released the hydrogen goes
to your your consumer and the consumer
produces the powerband when he or she
needs it and the water gets back into
the environment now first because I
talked to Ed if I made a left I made a
little change to my diagram but you just
point out load-leveling also applies to
nuclear to nuclear energy except the
other way around wind is on or is not on
you guys like to run on a level kill
right so you could have it equally well
like that but then my point is if I have
air capture working and you give me C or
two I can make you any hydrocarbon you
like and that's the argument I made a
second ago and that car runs a lot more
easily on a liquid fuel which may be
methanol it doesn't have to be gasoline
anymore but it what's nice about storing
storing energy and carbon compounds is
that it's a very simple storage and it's
a very compact because it has very high
energy density so that way you can close
the cycle so I see carbon neutral energy
systems they could happen with all sorts
of things i lumped together nuclear and
renew
mobile energy here because I feel those
two have in common that they don't
produce co2 you have coal tar sand shale
that's sort of the dirty fossil you have
natural gas which is getting bigger and
bigger right now and you have petroleum
and the petroleum sort of naturally
feeds the liquid fuels and the end
everybody else somehow another ends up
in electricity and flu synthesis gas
everybody could end up making liquid
fuels as well so you can now look at
this is all of the closest we would
could get too fast we could have
petroleum for a long time so this feeds
into the liquid fuels the mobile energy
demand is satisfied air capture collects
the sea or two and the co2 is put away
in carbon capture and storage the
renewable or nuclear sector just goes
along and may satisfy stationary energy
demand which I think ultimately will
beat coal plants which have to store
their sea or two I think you have a real
chance there to get cheaper but the
alternative of course is that if the
world where to run essentially on
natural gas we would make sense of this
gas and electricity the synthesis gas
would feed into the liquid fuel and
everybody would do carbon scrubbing
which goes into carbon capture and
storage but the last option is
everything comes from here no more co2
emissions or this end but now you would
like to have synthesis gas to have
liquid fuels they satisfy the mobile
energy demand a capture get you your co2
and water back which is then put back
into the synthesis gas with energy which
came from the electrolysis in
electricity from over here so I can have
it both ways and by the way this can now
act as feeding the transportation sector
but it can also feed the storage sector
for the energy side because one of the
things which hit me which is a very
simple calculation if you take a lithium
oxide battery and I'm now purposefully
pessimistic because numbers gets easy a
thousand dollars a kilowatt hours toward
my some people say it's down to 500 so
we're going to take 2000 I have a simple
rule of thumb one penny an hour
roughly ten percent on a thousand dollar
investment so if I have it because I'm
nearly 10,000 hours in here yay so if I
if I have a thousand dollar investment
and my clock ticks at a painting an hour
maybe it clicks at two cents an hour
because you want a little higher return
on this right if anything I'm low right
and so that takes care of your five
hundred dollars the other side but if
it's one penny an hour and I have a
diurnal swing on my battery I mean for
25 cents or 24 cents a kilowatt hour
right here and I haven't paid for the
fact that my battery may only have 400
cycles in which case and clearly did
because I added more than a dollar on
that but but it is it is that what gets
me it is not the price of the
electricity which came in I could have
lost two-thirds of it if I had off peak
electricity from a windmill I two cents
a kilowatt hour this only would drive me
up to six cents so the fact that a round
trip through chemistry is never very
efficient may actually not matter if the
cost of the electricity when I put it in
was cheap so I'm actually not afraid of
that and I would argue if you can get
cheap electricity you can solve your
storage problem on the chemical side and
forget all the other options they are
just a bonus if you get them so to me
and this is where I want to do close
this talk this is sort of a grander
vision way to go and why I think EA
capture has such a central position in
all of this because notice it doesn't
really matter which of these big energy
infrastructures will be the ones who win
in the end they all can benefit from
having the ability of having air capture
and on top of it you have the argument
we may find ourselves in a situation
where there's too much co2 in the air
already so some people accost me on us
to put it mildly they say this is really
evil what you are doing because it just
gives people an excuse not to do
anything right and I'm pointing out you
don't really want to get into this fight
with one of your hands tied behind your
back right and you may find out that
even with best effort we have to come
backwards in the co2 in the air
and I can't think of anything else but
this which could do it and to put it in
perspective the uptake rate of this one
ton a day unit if it were a tree of a
comparable size which I can really
envision it would collect tens of tons
over its lifetime right so this is
supposed to collect the ton attack so we
are roughly talking about a factor
thousands in collection efficiency
between biomass and this approach as a
consequence by the way all the algae
folks who want to make algae based fuels
found out that their outstrip the
ability of the algae to collect co2 they
like to have some ways of collecting the
co2 but that's sort of a side issue
whether it's what could go I'm just
trying to point out that the energy
systems in the future could benefit from
having liquid hydrocarbons around and if
they do that then they need air capture
because where every tonne of co2 going
in the air it has to come back out and
if you think biofuels they have to do it
because they they just happen to do it
by natural photosynthesis but it is a
air captures of sorts so there are any
questions I'm happy to answer I think
I've got through my slides i believe yes
yes well you I would expect it takes a
little longer than me hurriedly going
through a lot of slides but but I would
argue we are building small prototypes
at this point we are not yet a putana
day device we have worked over the last
year quite diligently inside the company
on getting much better than the 25 micro
moles per square meter per second and to
make these specific area much better so
this is where things are now I think the
next step would be to scale it up to 200
kilograms a day or so so you can
actually do precisely what you would
like to do the argument I would say at
this point a lot of this is still in the
paper stage right but practically
speaking I now have materials which
actually do absorb co2 I can get the co2
off those experiments are done what
where I'm still falling down I would
argue the underlying molecular mechanism
is semi understood I can hand wave my
way through and say this is how it works
but if we try to pinpoint it precisely I
would like to do a lot more experiments
to make that work but I have a
characterization which this this is the
partial pressure of co2 if I make it wet
this is the partial pressure if it's dry
in a dry climate it takes so long for it
to dry as it is
supposed to win so so there's a lot of
of those details there but I think the
next step is actually to move out and to
do just that and I would agree with you
and I think at the end you only know
after you did it whether we turn out to
be two hundred dollars a ton and never
get off that number or whether we can
actually systematically drive the cost
down and and here I'm the optimist
because otherwise I wouldn't be working
on it who says I think those steps can
be done but I think that these are
chicken in an egg yeah that they you
actually have to put the resources and
then make it happen and then see whether
you can go from there to the next step
from the company's point of view they
would love to sell so that gives you
stepping stones let's say we start at
five percent co2 in the exit string so
no evacuation you just make it wet you
collect the co2 at roughly five percent
and you feed it to algae right because
they want to buy co2 or you feed it into
a greenhouse in the Netherlands which is
not the climate we would like to work in
right now they pay roughly 100 euros for
a ton of co2 to feed it into a
greenhouse and where they diluted back
down because they want to be 900,000 ppm
inside so we would nicely be a fit to a
greenhouse which wants to keep the doors
closed and thereby contain heat and
thereby also operated elevated co2 which
tends to grow tomatoes faster so it is a
productivity enhancement for them and
that's why they pay a hundred dollars a
hundred euros a ton of co2 to make this
happen right there is an eight million
tonne a year market in in what I would
call merchant co2 in the US once you get
into you are they are 40 million times
so but none of that is big enough to
really deal with these big issues but i
do believe because it can start small
that you can actually sort of bootstrap
your way up whereas if you are at a
power plant you have to start big
because otherwise you didn't prove
anything so my my own but this is a
whole other talk my own view is that
these units don't want to get pretty
fully big they want to get mass-produced
and then if you want a thousand tons a
day in a place then you have
aggregate a thousand of these units into
one place but implicit in this is a is a
fairly sophisticated level of automation
because if I spend 30 minutes of
maintenance every day on a unit I just
blew my budget on on labor costs right
so so small units aggregated requires a
high level of automation and
sophistication that one but I do believe
ultimately the proof has to come from
doing and that's why I'm still engaged
with private enterprise on this because
otherwise in a university setting we can
talk about this for another 20 years and
it will gradually get more and more
sophisticated in our understanding but
it won't get much more practical yes yes
but it doesn't have 20 tons of stuff in
it yeah yeah it's a 40 40 foot shipping
container yes and they're about 50
million such containers out there
and that comes to the the point that new
hartford the environmental impact of
placing million 20 tons sized containers
so i understand me the capture the
synthesis but the actual storage well
assume assume for the sake of argument
right now australia has made the claim
that they have enormous saline aquifers
in inland somewhere in the day in the
australian desert right they have akwa
first there because that's what they
want to inject in one of the complaints
people have about injecting co2 you
raise the pressure we could use some of
the water which i didn't show you if you
do the calculation for desalinating sea
water and so you would look at brians
which are not extremely sailing if you
look at that that would would add less
than five that would add roughly five
dollars to a ton of co2 so so we could
afford that kind of level of energy so
if you are now in that desert yes you
would create a big cluster of them and
put 10,000 hundred thousands in one
place and they would inject co2
underground into those reservoirs the
point is you would go where you know
what to do with a co2 not to a random
place right so you would be on top of a
storage facility or you would be if you
ain't enhanced oil recovery you would
put them up into the field where you
want the enhanced oil recovery to happen
because one of the advantages you have
the transport works was free for you so
you would like to go where you can use
the stuff so as a result i'm also keenly
interested in eliminating the humidity
limit we have right now right the
material sort of rolls over from a state
where absorbs into a state very d sorbs
and unfortunately it starts doing that
at a um
you might have in singapore right and so
I would love to modify the material so
that that transition happens a little at
a little higher level of humidity right
because I'd like to be I'd like to be
capable to work in any climate right and
therefore go to any location but but I
feel former starting point of view if i
can get a foothold in a desert and show
this works i have started so then then i
can can afterwards worry how to get it
into a different climate but there are
competitors out now they say we use a
thermal slip and so they have to say how
to pay for all the heat we have to say
how do we pay for all the water and
since they are thermal swing they are
pretty insensitive to the water you to
try yes
yes assume assume I have thirty dollars
a ton right the lifetime emissions of a
car on the order of a hundred tons of
co2 right so for an extra three thousand
dollars at thirty dollars a ton you can
make a single car lifetime carbon-free
not the time you hold the car but
lifetime carbon free because they last
on the order of 10 12 years and you may
have sold it after three or four so yes
you could do that you could have a
tanker coming into a harbor and you can
save these 300,000 tons of oil on board
which are roughly a million tons of co2
has been neutralized up front so these
are these are to me bootstrapping ways
of getting into this I think ultimately
you need a government regulation which
says you have to buy that offset now
this is a voluntary offset and I think
right now people are not willing to pay
four dollars a ton and certainly not the
two hundred dollars a ton where we think
we'll we'll get our foot in the door but
it turns out in Phoenix Arizona in 2008
because I paid attention that here a ton
of co2 in that local market was selling
at three hundred dollars and the reason
this is the case because the co2 is
basically driven by the transport costs
and it came from Los Angeles way it's
fifty dollars and the right on the truck
for sleep one of the 500 miles herself
ended up adding driving the price
absolutely in a doll as a time so so
there are niches way even with a higher
prices you can start but ultimately yes
this is the offset and I just said I
just suggested ultimately you have to
and a that in the short term you can get
volunteers and sort of the order of
magnitude is thousands of dollars per
car yes there are smaller scale options
but it turns out the amount of co2 we
make is just very large right in the
u.s. it's 20 tons I don't know what it
is in France I would guess it's probably
seven or eight tons of co2 per person
per year right so if you look if you
look at those kind of numbers and say
what do you do on that scale well this
is these 20 tons of the US would be 50
tons of carbonate a year because you
have to go energetically downhill if you
don't turn it back into a fuel and the
only thing downhill are the carbonates
right so you end up saying okay how many
Greek Revival columns can I put in front
of my house because I can make three or
four a year right and so you pretty soon
we don't consume things short of water
on that scale right and so I see yes I
see plenty of smaller things we can get
into the concrete market you can get
people talk about Simmons which I've
carbonate based and all of those things
can absorb a little here in a little
there but in the end you took one ton a
day one time a person a year or why and
you are left with a 19 at the other hand
so I'm looking at the the big options
our disposal right and people call it
storage which sounds so much more benign
but really its disposal or recycle to
what it was and that is fuel right and
that means you had a cheap energy source
in the in your back pocket because
otherwise you can't afford it yes
i yes we looked we looked at various
options and this is early I think fifty
percent efficiency is ambitious but not
not outrageous so so if you were to look
at these various options electrolysis
can be a lot more than that and and you
can push fischer-tropsch into the fifty
sixty percent so if you multiply this
together you you can aim for about fifty
percent right so basically you need and
that's what I included when I said
forties I assumed it costs you 2020
kilowatt hours to make a gallon of
gasoline rather than the 10 which is
what's chemically in it right and and
round trip efficiencies you can get to a
third and so by the time if you started
with electricity when it was cheap and
you ended up with electricity when it's
expensive you probably got one third
pack